hi i'm joelle and pelman from the prom
on netflix and i am this week's agony
and in glamorous problem solve
[Music]
dear joellen i feel like an outsider in
my own life and can't find my people
what steps would you recommend for me
getting out there
and finding my people kind regards all
of the outsider
this is such a good question i would
focus on two areas one
in real life so i would if there's a
hobby that you've been wanting to
take up or if you're at school i would
say like join a new club
like find other people with like
interests
and i think you might be surprised at
what kind of connections come from that
dear joellen my confidence is very low
and i want to finally become the leading
lady of my own life
i need to bring out my inner musical
diva what three steps do you recommend
yours broadway beverly okay so
i think number one get a great broadway
playlist
like for me it would be a combination of
like
legally blonde i would have some
like hamilton on there just like any
kind of music that makes me
feel unstoppable and then i would
put on probably like my favorite outfit
um probably something with a lot of like
sparkles and i would just
like dance around my house and really
just feel like i'm on a stage
you're joellen i need to inject some
serious style into my life
this loungewear life has chosen me and
i'm sick of it
what makeover tips can you share best
unfashionable female
fiona there is nothing wrong with a
loungewear life i've literally
been spending all of my days in
loungewear
and it's the best thing ever it's so
comfortable so i think there's
no reason that can't be stylish you can
always like put on a cool hat or like
wear
you know some fun jewelry along with
your loungewear dear joellen
my dating game needs a little zazz i
haven't had a date all year how can i
raise my game
do i stay off the apps or hope to meet
someone irl
in life kind regards on the shelf sue
sue i hear you
um you are so not alone and feeling like
the dating game just like is not
happening right now but
and i feel like that's i mean that's
kind of because of kovid
um so don't feel like you need to go on
dates
like always protect your safety overall
but i would also say like the apps are
kind of
the best way to meet people right now
that we are you know
you know all inside so i would say
i would say try it dear joellen my enemy
at work is out to get me
how can i maneuver them and come out as
top dog
best sally the schemer sally
i think you should talk this out with
a therapist or a trusted friend um
you know competitive environments in the
workplace are really toxic
i would just take a step back and maybe
start
looking for new jobs if that's possible
for you um
because i don't i don't want you to feel
like you have to outmaneuver someone
like that's just
that's really stressful for everyone and
you deserve to be
working in a place that you know you
feel
comfortable and safe then dear joellen i
have my eyes on someone special and i
want to grab their attention on the
dance floor
what dance move would you recommend best
wannabe sexy steve i think
that any kind of especially like
disco dance move is really fun
um and it's pretty easy anyone can do it
and i think you're gonna look great and
honestly just like dance
in whatever way makes you comfortable
but like if i were gonna do it i would
do something like disco
something like that all right and that's
it for me
for more glamour problem solved videos
subscribe now
you